thanks to expressvpn for keeping legal
eagles safe and in the air in the wake
of systemic police abuse that was
brought to a head by what we saw with
George Floyd people are out in the
streets and they are demanding police
reform and it's an idea whose time has
come
but apart from just entirely disbanding
the police what can we possibly do well
as an officer of the court I have some
ideas
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because it appears that the
time has come for true police reform we
cannot settle for anything less than
transformative structural change a broad
coalition of people are working to
change the way that police departments
operate legislators are writing bills
state and local governments as well as
the federal government seem to have
heard those cries and appeared to be
amenable for something that was
completely off the table just a few
short months ago but that raises the
question if we're going to change the
way the police operate what exactly are
we going to do the good and bad news is
that a lot of the reforms that people
are calling for are very easy to
implement
it only takes the political will to do
so and changing the way the police
operate can be a very very difficult
task in political economy and
traditionally speaking politicians love
the police it's hard to lose an election
battle if you are on the side of the
police departments we have to respect
our police we have to take care of our
police they're protecting this and being
tough on crime which is one of the
reasons why it's been so difficult to
usher in police reform but perhaps the
time is now there seems to be a broad
coalition growing and calling for real
concrete steps and the good news is
there's tons of low-hanging fruit for
police reform that will lead to more
just outcomes for almost everyone and
more just policing but before we dive
into some of these reforms some of which
I think are complete no-brainers let's
talk for a second about the problems
with maximalism and trade offs because
in this debate people want different
things
some people want safety low crime others
want human dignity and justice taxpayers
want low cost and low taxes some people
want higher enforcement of crimes and
punishment rates police officers often
want jobs safety and other individuals
want privacy and a lot of these
different things are at odds with each
other and we have to recognize that when
you turn one of these dials the other
dials move so it's possible that some of
these reforms might cost more tax money
some of these reforms might result in
fewer crimes being punished when the
crime actually occurs some of these
reforms might cause police officers to
be less safe in their job
and these are all trade offs I'm not
here to choose which one is more
important than the other but all of
these dials move in conjunction with
each other and there are going to be
trade offs with some of these particular
reforms I happen to personally believe
that we should move the dial in terms of
justice and fairness with respect to
individual citizens and if that means
some higher costs well that might be a
trade off that's worthwhile but it would
be very silly to claim that all of these
reforms are going to be a free lunch
there's no such thing as a free lunch
but let's talk about some of the reforms
that are in the air I'm not here to
advocate for any particular one of these
but I think a lot of these potential
reforms have the potential to really be
a game changer when it comes to justice
and fairness throughout America when it
comes to the police so in no particular
order here are some ideas that really
could make a huge difference when it
comes to fairness and the police first
body cameras a lot of jurisdictions
don't have body cameras luckily there
are a lot of federal programs that help
provide funding to local municipal
police departments so that they can
provide body cameras when it wouldn't
otherwise be in the budget but the
technology exists for body cameras on
police officers to record basically
continuously while that police officer
is patrolling and it seems crazy that
the police officer would have the
control to be able to turn off and on
the body camera at whim and we've seen
instances where police officers have
actually planted drugs on suspects and
then turn their body camera on minutes
later and the only reason we know that
is the police officer didn't know that
the body camera had a pre record
functionality but let's do away with all
that and just have body cameras on all
the time and there could be penalties
for police officers that intentionally
block or turn off their body cameras
during important events and this is one
reform that I think most police officers
should be in favor of because well the
cultural zeitgeist is full of accounts
horrific accounts of police misconduct
especially in the wake of peaceful
protests it'd be silly to think that all
of the complaints against the police are
meritorious in fact probably the
majority of the complaints that are made
against police are not meritorious and
are probably made by criminals who are
not happy with the fact that they were
arrested so having footage of
interactions with potential suspects
where the police can clearly show that
they engaged in no misconduct in nearest
to the benefits of the police as well
and next is the issue of public access
to information regarding police
misconduct
now we've already acknowledged that some
police misconduct or allegations of
police misconduct is completely
fabricated but also some of that
information is absolutely not
fabricated and we have to admit that the
police engage in misconduct and it's
important that because police are public
servants that not just convictions
regarding police misconduct but also
even allegations of police misconduct be
made available to both the cities and
the people who those cities serve and
the statistics tend to bear this out as
well that only a small number of police
officers are responsible for the vast
majority of allegations and convictions
of police misconduct so it's very
important to have access to that data
that information to know who those
potential bad apples are and you always
have a bad apple no matter where you go
you have bad apples and they're not too
many of them and I can tell you that not
too many of them in the police
department by the way the metaphor of
the Bann apples it's being thrown around
a lot especially by police officers and
police departments claiming that it's
only a couple of bad apples well
remember that analogy is that a handful
of bad apples will spoil the entire
barrel of apples so when you have a
potential systemic issue the fact that
you're pointing to a couple of bad
apples doesn't actually support your
argument that it's individuals and not
the system itself because those couple
of bad actors those bad apples can have
a corrupting influence on the rest of
the entire department so be careful what
metaphors you use in what particular
context it's important to know what
those words mean but even if we were to
take the idea that these are isolated
individuals that don't have a larger
systemic issue one of the more meta
things that police departments
I think should do is inculcate this
culture of weeding out the bad apples
from the rest of the department
certainly they're going to be
individuals who are worse than other
individuals and they might have a
corrupting influence and
the stats bear out that they might be
responsible for more of the misconduct
than other people so if you are a good
police officer who is not engaging in
misconduct you should want to get those
other people out but what we've seen is
that this blue wall or this blue line
prevents getting out the bad actors so I
would like to see and I don't know how
one would accomplish this per se but
Police Department should have a culture
of weeding out the bad apples because
they shouldn't be there one way you
might do that is by having a whistle
blower system that tends to exist on the
federal level though that's being eroded
day by day still the idea of whistle
blowers or providing rewards to
individuals who are willing to buck the
trend of the rest of the department to
be able to report and get rid of bad
actors where they exist I think that
that is a very meritorious system a good
philosophy and I don't know how one
would do that but it's it's something
that police departments should aspire to
though on the other side if that is the
carrot in terms of getting people to
report bad behavior this stick portion
of that would be a duty to report such
that if you witness bad conduct taking
place and this does exist in some police
departments then the individual officers
have a duty to report that bad conduct
up the chain or to investigative affairs
but you could take a two-pronged
approach you can reward whistleblowers
who come forward and you can also create
a duty to report such that individual
officers are liable when they fail to
report egregious conduct but when you're
talking about the culture of the police
department it's impossible to overlook
the elephant in the room
and that's police unions this is
probably one potential avenue that's
going to be the most divisive even
amongst people that want to reform
police departments but there is no
argument that police unions have a huge
amount of power and partly it's by
design police unions are designed so
that they create collective bargaining
power so that they can help police
officers get more favorable working
conditions and more favorable terms
under which they work the downside to
that is that the police union has as a
client its police officers I will defend
those that stand here I
defend my family I will defend our
citizens both here and a woman now in
phase one going back to work and often
what's in the best interest of the
community is not in the best interest of
the police officers themselves or the
police union writ large and part of the
issue here is that some of the things
that the police unions often negotiate
over are not just things like salary or
hours or retirement benefits but things
like what happens when individual police
officers are accused of misconduct often
you'll see in the collective bargaining
agreements that the police officers if
they are accused of egregious misconduct
have a certain cooling-off period where
it might be 48 or 72 hours before other
police officers are even allowed to
interview the police officers accused of
misconduct of what actually happened and
what we have seen is that during that
amount of time think about what they're
going to say to the people who are
investigating they think about getting
their stories straight they think about
what particular chain of events would be
most beneficial to themselves and it
will not surprise you that if you are a
normal citizen who is accused of
criminal misconduct you don't get the
same kind of protections that the police
do because of the contracts that are
written into the collective bargaining
agreements between the police union and
the police departments and I've heard
stories of police unions giving
individual officers a more or less a
script to recite when they are accused
of unlawful use of force and so they can
get their story to line up with the
thing that is the best legal defense and
the only thing option left was my
firearm this has to work as I'm you know
I'm gonna be done he's gonna get this
gun away from me something's gonna
happen and I'm gonna be dead
and these are just a handful of examples
how in many ways police officers get
special treatment when they are accused
of misconduct on their own and that's
not to say that police unions don't
provide real benefits but if people are
really serious about creating a more
just and fair system for everyone not
just police officers certainly people
are gonna have to take a serious look at
the power the police unions have in this
country and because of the power that
police unions have in this country it's
often been
difficult to get police reforms because
as a political entity they tend to fight
any kind of change at all beginning
today as chief I am immediately
withdrawing from the contract
negotiations with the Minneapolis Police
Federation I plan to bring in subject
matter experienced and advisers to
conduct a thorough review of how the
contract can be restructured to provide
greater community transparency and more
flexibility for a true reform so if we
were going to use a general principle
here we might say that perhaps there can
be a rule that says police officers
can't get any special treatment above
and beyond what any other normal citizen
would get when accused of criminal
misconduct and when it comes to police
oversight perhaps we should rethink the
idea that the police are able to police
themselves where instead of the police
overseeing themselves there is a board
of civilians released non police
officers who are able to look at the
potential misconduct and make a
judgement over it and perhaps even
better than just a civilian oversight
board is a civilian oversight board with
the ability to make high-stakes
decisions that if they do find
misconduct they are able to levy
penalties against the police officers or
potentially even fire them though
obviously this is something that police
unions want to fight against because
they don't want some other third party
having sway over individual police
officers but it's something that other
police departments have done and can
make sure that when there is misconduct
that the bad actors are punished for it
and on that score
perhaps an obvious one is real
consequences for bad conduct when there
is a conviction for police misconduct
there need to be real stakes so that
individuals are punished for engaging in
that kind of misconduct and one way that
is sort of in the cultural zeitgeist
these days is ending or limiting what's
called qualified immunity now this is a
topic for another day I'm going to do
another set of videos regarding what's
called a section 1983 claim under the
federal law which is limited by this
immunity that police officers often
receive called qualified immunity which
is an impediment to some federal law
suits being served against individual
police officers and individual
departments but suffice to say there are
bills before Congress that would
abrogate this immunity this qualified
immunity for the police officers and
police departments which might provide
an incentive to not engage in misconduct
or at least try and curtail it because
if they're all these lawsuits and then
the police departments don't want to get
defunded so I will cover that in depth
in future videos because it's a very
very complicated subject and in terms of
the real nuts and bolts there is a
movement on social media called 8 can't
wait for 8 particular tactics that a
particular group thinks would make a big
difference in terms of making police
departments less violence these 8
particular tactics include banning
chokeholds outright which many police
departments have done although
Minneapolis is a notable exception to
that requiring de-escalation before
moving forward with violent force
requiring a warning before shooting
exhausting all other means before
shooting creating a duty to intervene so
that when police officers see criminal
misconduct or can help an individual
they intervene in that situation banning
shooting at moving vehicles requiring a
use of force continuum before escalating
and requiring comprehensive reporting of
use of force I'd recommend taking a
deeper dive into the stats that this
movement has has offered about the
efficacy but there's definitely some
potential in some of these reforms to
create a less violent Police Department
now in a prior video I mentioned that
saying police officers or soldiers and a
war for America makes them sort of feel
like soldiers and when that happens the
police acts more like soldiers than
actual police but one of the other
reasons why police officers engage in
additional military or violent tactics
is that they are clad in all kinds of
surplus military equipment now one of
the reasons that we've seen that over
the last few years is that there is a
federal law that allows the federal
government to give Police Department's
surplus military equipment at cost or at
no cost so long as they use that
equipment within one year so I probably
don't need to tell you that this creates
all kinds of
backwards incentives number one police
departments are going to want to do what
they can to get free military equipment
and number two the law is currently
written incentivizes them to actually
use it to on a use-it-or-lose-it basis
and I'll be the first to admit that
driving around in a repurposed Humvee or
MRAP looks like a whole lot of fun but
the last thing that we want to do is to
make police feel like they're soldiers
on the frontlines of America that's not
how you get just outcomes for citizens
it's no wonder that police wearing riot
gear being transported around in troop
carriers feel like soldiers and that
leads to escalation then we've seen that
with peaceful protesters and that seems
like the very last thing that we want
and another potential way to limit the
number of violent encounters that happen
with police in sort of an
outside-the-box thinking is perhaps we
need to send non police sometimes in
America pretty much everyone knows how
to dial the police 911 but often the
police might not be the right people the
the right public servants to send to any
given situation perhaps we need to
rethink when we deploy the police so for
example say that someone is having an
issue with someone who has a mental
health issue instead of sending the
police which is basically the default in
America perhaps we can send a non police
health worker or a social worker that if
things escalate if things are likely to
get potentially violent or if there is a
violent crime potentially perpetrated
then at that point the police can be
called but perhaps the first person who
is called is not a police officer but
that does remind me of something that
I've seen in particular in Washington DC
which is that when police officers are
called I think everyone would agree
those officers need to be clearly
identified recently we've seen all kinds
of unidentified military and police
officers roaming the streets of
Washington DC with no clear
identification and I think a very very
good thing that pretty much everyone has
a video camera in their pocket and
they're able to document police
misconduct when it happens and we've
certainly seen hundreds if not thousands
of examples of that during the protests
some obviously some force
was was probably justified during riots
and looting but by and large the
protests have been peaceful so when you
have police using force using rubber
bullets using the tear gas we need to
know who these individuals are let alone
times when they're using force deadly or
not to subdue potential suspects and in
terms of protests we might consider
banning the use of rubber bullets and
tear gas in general it's not clear that
the police have the rules available to
use that kind of equipment responsibly
now obviously there are times when
they're going to be protests and riots
that are much more violent than what
we've seen as of late but perhaps as a
general rule or with a very specific
escalation of force we might put rules
in place that prevent them from using
those kind of those tools in these
circumstances and of course it's
important to acknowledge that police
have a dangerous job but sometimes that
danger is overblown if I can digress for
a moment
currently the stats show that the police
officer is the fourteenth most dangerous
job in the United States
somewhere between taxi drivers and
construction workers so sure being a
police officer might be considered a
dangerous job but there are many many
other jobs that are actually much more
dangerous than being a police officer
and obviously these individuals receive
none of the kinds of protections when
people accuse them of misconduct and one
of the more meta things that definitely
strikes close to home is that we have a
lot of laws in this country and
theoretically every single law that's on
the books could result in someone with a
gun trying to enforce it and we've seen
relatively minor infractions leading to
a suspect being killed whether it's
kiting checks or passing a bad bill or
trying to sell cigarettes without the
correct certification those are all
examples of people who were accused of
minor minor crimes that because the
police were called and admittedly they
had breached those laws they were
detained using violent force and
individuals died as a result of those so
perhaps we need to rethink some of the
laws that are on the books or at the
very least authorization
of using physical or violent force to
detain people who are accused of very
minor crimes now some people might not
like that because it might lead to laws
being not enforced but I think as a
society we need to ask ourselves what
kind of laws justify the potential for
someone dying as a result of breaching
that law and since we're on the topic of
police enforcing minor sometimes
misdemeanor laws perhaps we might
consider disassociating the revenue that
comes from those penalties from police
departments because often the police
departments directly benefit from that
revenue it's hard to not think of
Ferguson where there was an entire
police culture of trying to get as much
money from penalties as possible things
like speeding tickets are penalties from
misdemeanors all of that revenue when it
was generated often from very low income
communities went directly to the police
department so it created this terrible
incentive of being very very particular
about enforcing everything and getting
as much money as possible from the
community so if the police department
didn't benefit from that revenue it
might create an incentive not
necessarily to enforce some of these
very low-level infractions and speaking
of the community we might want more
community involvement from police some
of the police departments that have done
a generally very good job have been
proactive about trying to make sure that
not only the high level police officers
but even mid and low level police
officers are involved in the community
people often talk about requiring police
to live in the areas that they actively
police but that's probably more of a
proxy for just knowing the community
itself knowing who is there getting to
know those people and instead of all
police interactions being only when
things have gone wrong showing that the
police presence is there to help the
community to listen to the community
ahead of time and really having that
institutional knowledge instead of
waiting for things to go bad and only
having police interactions being at the
point of a gun though one of the issues
here is that often police departments
are just a patchwork quilt throughout
the entire United States with no
overarching guidelines and and no data
sharing and often the police departments
don't have the budget to do those sort
of things so it might be important
federal government to take an oversight
role here perhaps there can be a central
federal oversight or data Clearing House
Center where the federal government
provides the funds and the manpower to
gather all of the relevant statistics
and to provide some oversight to all of
the different states and individual
police departments throughout and on a
more coercive tax per haps the federal
government through the Department of
Justice needs to get more involved in
terms of investigating individual Police
Department's and states that have a
systemic issue effectively over the last
few years the department has stopped
investigating individual Police
Department's and I can't remember the
time the Department of Justice issued a
consent decree against individual police
departments to help enforce rights and
that's a worrying trend because that's
one of the oversight roles of the
Department of Justice and while the
federal government should probably have
some oversight role over state and local
police departments we don't want the
police having too much oversight over
you so if you're using the internet out
in the wild and you don't want the
police looking at your internet traffic
you should definitely try expressvpn for
those of you who don't already know a
VPN basically creates a secure tunnel
from whatever device you're using and
the Internet
keeping your digital privacy intact and
it's a big issue because every time you
connect to an unencrypted Wi-Fi network
at airports hotels coffee shops and even
at home you're at risk expressvpn
encrypts your internet connections using
the highest standards of encryption
currently available a big problem in the
u.s. is that ISPs track and sell your
browsing habits to advertisers in my
experience expressvpn is also the
fastest VPN by far and with expressvpn
you can also reroute your connection to
a server in a country of your choice
giving you unrestricted access to parts
of the Internet and making geo
restrictions a thing of the past
take watching Netflix for example say I
want to watch one of my favorite British
sci-fi shows about a time-traveling
alien doctor what can I say
I'm a fan but the selection with me
being in the United States isn't the
same as if I was in the UK so once I
switched my VPN I can watch pretty much
whatever I want whatever I want
or maybe I want to see what's trending
in YouTube and Belgium or Japan I can
route my traffic there I'm huge in Japan
I assume expressvpn also has 24/7
customer support which means your
questions will be answered within
seconds not hours and you don't have to
take my word for it
VPN is rated number one by TechRadar
seen at the verge and compare tech and
many others so if you want to join just
head over to expressvpn dot-com slash
legal eagle right now and find out how
you can get three months free again
that's expressvpn comm slash legal eagle
or just click the link down in the
description plus click them at link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis are there other
ways that we should reform the police or
should we leave the police just the way
that they are leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other analysis
about legal issues raised in the news
today and just click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court